hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem find minimum in
a rotated sorted array so we are given
an input array of length n that is
assorted in ascending order but it could
be rotated
one to n times for example if we have an
array like one two
one zero one two right to rotate it by
one basically means to take the
rightmost element you know move it to
the beginning
like this right so this has been rotated
by one we could also rotate it by two by
taking the last two elements and moving
them to the beginning so something like
this right this has been rotated by two
and so we want to find the minimum value
and we want to do it in log n time as
they say the good thing is that we do
have some kind of sorting property that
we can use to our advantage to find this
log n time solution and we are
guaranteed that every value in the array
happens to be unique of course it would
be easy to find a linear time solution
basically just scan through every single
value in the array and then take the
minimum value and return it but we can
use the sorting property to our
advantage even if the array has been
rotated let me show you how we can do
that solution as you might be able to
guess it is going to involve the binary
search algorithm which is usually the
algorithm that runs in log and time so
the fact that the array was originally
sorted is what hints to you that binary
search might work in this case but it's
not going to be a traditional binary
search now of course if the entire array
was sort was uh rotated n times that
basically means we took a sorted array
such as one two three four five rotated
it n times basically leaving it in the
original sorted order now if we had an
array that was completely sorted like
this one an easy binary search would
work on a sorted array but if the array
is fully sorted then we know that the
minimum value is going to be the
leftmost right so if at any point we get
a you know binary search is going to run
like this a left pointer and a right
pointer if we ever get to a point where
the entire array is sorted we can just
return the leftmost element or at least
consider this as being the minimum value
so let's try a binary search and see how
it's going to be different than a
regular binary search now of course we
want to find the minimum value we're
going to initialize our left pointer
here and our right pointer here
basically the current pointer situation
means that we are considering this
entire array to find the minimum the
minimum could be from anywhere in this
array and the result is going to be the
minimum and i'm going to keep track of
that over here now of course one way we
could do this problem is basically find
the pivot right find the position where
you know the
the elements are not in
increasing order right from from here to
here three to four they're in an
increasing order from four to five there
they are in increasing order from one to
two they're also in increasing order but
from five to one they're in decreasing
order this is the pivot right so
basically this value is going to be the
minimum but i'm going to do it in a
slightly different way where we don't
necessarily have to you know look
exactly for the pivot i'm going to take
okay left right take the half of them
get our middle pointer our middle is
going to be over here at 5. so i'm going
to consider as 5 being the minimum value
we have seen so far right so our result
is going to be five now
now we have to ask ourselves okay
you know this could have been the result
but now we don't want to you know look
at this value again so the question
becomes are we going to search to the
left or are we going to search to the
right where are we going to find the
minimum value where are we going to find
a value that's even smaller than 5. well
first consider this
since we rotated the array we have two
portions of the array that are sorted
right we have this portion of the array
that's sorted the left portion right and
we have the right sorted portion of the
array which is also sorted so the
question is for us with this middle
pointer at this value 5 are we currently
in the left sorted portion or are we
currently in the right sorted portion
now if we are in the left sorted portion
of the array don't we want to search the
right sorted portion reason being if we
sorted the if we rotated the array the
left portion is always going to have
values that are greater than every value
in the right sorted portion right
because when we rotate right suppose an
array like this we're taking the the
rightmost value the largest value and
putting it over here right so we're
taking larger values putting them on the
left side right so therefore the values
on the right are going to be smaller now
so that's why it's always going to be
that way so if our middle pointer is
currently in a value that's in the left
sorted portion then we want to search
the right sorted portion because it has
smaller values in it right so how can we
know if we are in the left sorted
portion well like i said every value in
the right sorted portion is going to be
smaller than every value in the left
sorted portion so one thing we can check
is if the current middle value is
greater than or equal to the value all
the way at the left of our thing right
because the left value is going to be
the smallest value if the middle value
is greater than or equal to the leftmost
value that means this middle value is a
part of this left sorted portion right
in which case we want to search to the
right now if our middle pointer suppose
in this case we can see five is greater
than or equal to three the the reason
we're doing greater than or equal is
technically this middle pointer could
actually be at the left position as well
that's one edge case and in that case we
would also you know this would be the
left sorted portion but suppose our
middle pointer instead of being at five
was actually over here it was at one
what would our condition evaluate to
that numbs of middle would be one is
that greater than or equal to the left
value which is three it's not right
because the values in this right sorted
portion are going to be smaller than the
left sorted portion in which case this
would evaluate to false right if it's
false that means you know if we're at a
value that's in the right sorted portion
then we want to search to the left right
because in this case the the right if if
our middle was at this it makes sense
that okay you know all the values to the
right of it are going to be greater so
then we want to search to the left but
obviously these values are also greater
but that kind of doesn't illustrate the
point because what if our middle pointer
was over here right maybe we had some
values over here
you know this is where our middle
pointer is we see two okay
two could have been the minimum then we
want to search to the left because we
want to find even smaller values
particularly we would want to find this
one that happens to be smaller because
we don't know where the pivot is the
pivot could be here the pivot could be
here it could be anywhere we just know
we have to look to the left if we want
to find smaller elements if we if our
middle pointer happens to be in the
right sorted portion then we want to
search to the left if our middle pointer
is in the left sorted portion then we
want to search to the right and i just
showed you the condition we can use to
detect that so now i'm going to run
through the example and it'll probably
make more sense and by the way the
algorithm i'm describing only works on a
on a rotated sorted array if we ever got
to a point where our let's say our right
pointer was over here meaning that you
know this is our entire search range
then we could not do this algorithm in
this case if we ever got to a a portion
of the array that's completely sorted we
would just take the leftmost value and
see if it's smaller than our current
result and then we would stop the entire
binary search okay so now let's run
through the example these are the
conditions that i talked about that
we're going to be using so our middle
pointer is here let's check is so you
know we we checked that this might be
the minimum now we're never going to
look at this again so now we're going to
check is this value greater than the
value all the way to the left yes it is
so we're going to search right since
we're searching right that means we're
never going to search these values again
so we can cross them out we're going to
take our left pointer and
shift it to mid plus one so our left
pointer is now going to be over here
this is our new search range and as you
can see this portion of the array is
already in sorted order right how do we
know that because our the point the
value at our right pointer is greater
than the value at our left pointer so
that means that the array is entirely
sorted and then we can just take the
leftmost value here which is one see if
it's smaller than our current result yes
it is so then we can return one in this
case now just to kind of illustrate the
opposite case arbitrarily i'm just going
to say our middle pointer is actually
gonna be over here for some random
reason let's just see how our binary
search would work in that case well we
would take this middle value say that it
might be our result so our result is
gonna initially be one and then we're
gonna run through these conditions is
the middle value greater than or equal
to the leftmost value it's not so we
execute the else case which basically
means we're searching left right so
we're going to take uh you know this is
not going to be considered again we're
going to take our right pointer set it
to mid minus 1. so our right pointer is
going to be over here and we're going to
cross out 2 because it's never going to
be searched right because we shifted our
pointer this is our new search range
once again you can see that this range
is sorted basically the left value is
smaller than the right value so this is
already sorted we can take the leftmost
value over here c is this smaller than
our current result it's not so our
result stays the same and we don't have
to search this entire portion because
it's already sorted so that's kind of
the general idea of how this algorithm
is going to work it's pretty easy once
you kind of figure out these two
conditions with that being said we can
jump into the code okay so now let's get
into the code as i mentioned we are
going to be maintaining a result now we
can set this to some arbitrary default
value i'm just going to set it to nums
of 0. we could just pick any value in
the input array nums but i'm just going
to choose the leftmost
just because
we're also going to have our two
pointers initially left is going to be
all the way at the left index zero right
is going to be at the rightmost index
length of nums minus one and we're going
to keep running our binary search while
our pointers are in a valid
position while left is less than or
equal to right and like i mentioned if
we ever get to a subarray that's already
sorted basically if the value at the
left is
uh less than the value at the right then
we can update our result potentially
setting the result to the minimum of
itself and the leftmost value of this
sorted portion and then we can break out
of this while loop
if the array is not sorted that's when
we're actually going to be doing our
binary search portion so we can compute
the mid uh the midpointer basically left
plus right integer division by two
and with this mid value we're going to
potentially update our results setting
the result equal to the minimum of
itself and the value at the mid pointer
and once we're done with that now we
want to know are we going to search to
the left or are we going to search to
the right so how can we determine that
as i mentioned the condition we want to
know is this mid value a part of the
left sorted portion it is a part of the
left sorted portion if the value at the
middle index is greater than or equal to
the value all the way at the left that
means it is a part of the left sorted
portion in which case we want to search
the right sorted portion so we can take
our midpointer set it take our left
pointer set it to mid plus one now the
else case is if we're in the right
sorted portion in which case we want to
search to the left so we set the right
pointer equal to mid minus one and we're
going to keep doing that until we find
the solution or until our binary search
has basically searched the entire array
and then after that we can go ahead and
return the result value as you can see
this solution does run it's pretty uh
short and concise i'm sure there are
ways you can make it even shorter but it
runs pretty efficiently so i hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it supports the channel a
lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching